today on the matt walsh show the cdc has
given us permission to breathe fresh air
again
some of us anyway many people have been
waiting for this permission and are
grateful that the cdc will allow them
to show their faces in public again i
think it's a rather pitiful and
embarrassing picture altogether
and we'll talk about it today also five
headlines including the hackers who
caused a gas shortage across the u.s
win a big ransom for their troubles aoc
calls in extra security because another
member of congress
yelled at her and disney goes for gold
in the woke olympics with its new
cartoon show featuring interracial gay
dads
and finally in our daily cancellation
we'll discuss the american idol
contestant who was forced off the show
for something he posted
on the internet when he was 12 years old
12
and he's canceled for that all of that
and more today on the matt wall show
[Music]
now checking in with our friends over at
rock auto you know i hate to say that
i've had
so many occasions to use rock auto
recently because we've had we
have had a lot of car trouble but the
good thing is if you do have car trouble
which nobody wants that
rockauto.com is going to make it a lot
easier for you because you don't have to
go to the rut to the auto parts store
deal with all that
and you know when you go to rockauto.com
it's extremely easy to navigate you can
find everything you're looking for
and you know that whatever you find it's
gonna be the the best price
available um if you find it there
then you probably will find what you're
looking for because the selection is
great you know that that's the best
price you're going to find rockauto.com
is
also a family business they've been
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
the rockauto.com catalog again is is
unique and
very easy to get through you don't have
to be i'm not an expert myself or
anything close to it
um but you don't have to be in order to
get through and
find what you're looking for you can
quickly see all the parts available for
your car
truck so again go to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available
and as always write walsh in there how
did you hear about us box so they know
that we sent you
this has been a tough week for those of
us who have a weak
stomach mayor bill de blasio really
tested our intestinal
resolve when he unveiled new york's
ingenious new plan to incentivize
vaccinations in the city
as the mayor explained while munching
like a disgusting cow
anyone who gets vaccinated will be
eligible for free french fries and a
hamburger from shake shack
or you know you could just pay the six
dollars and buy it yourself
anyway here is bill de blasio making his
pitch with a mouthful of half-chewed
food
free fries when you get vaccinated um
i got vaccinated
you're saying i could get this delicious
fries
right but there's also a burger element
to this
let me let me check with bill neathhardt
is it too early in the day to eat a bird
this could be breakfast okay
i want you to look at this and think
about
again some people love hamburgers some
don't really want to respect
all ways of life but if this is
appealing to you just think of this when
you think of vaccination
vaccinations
i'm getting a very good feeling
about vaccination right this moment
by the way what was the guy who he was
talking to what was his name bill
meatard
was that was that his name i i didn't
really hear it but
anyway that's horrifying uh it is it's a
rare talent to make
french fries seem unappealing but de
blasio's pulled it off speaking of which
what kind of person picks up a french
fry takes three bites of it then puts
the remainder of the fry back down
and moves on to the hamburger did you
see him do that who does that he didn't
even finish the one french fry he was
holding
takes two bites and puts it down picks
up the hamburger returns to the french
fry
the man eats like some sort of martian
body snatcher who's never consumed
earthly
food before so no surprise there i
suppose more to the point
this strategy for pushing vaccinations
is incredibly
insulting as well as nauseating do they
really think that a person hesitated
about getting vaccinated for whatever
reason is going to be swayed by the
promise of a fast food coupon
the assumption is that an unvaccinated
person must necessarily have
frivolous and stupid reasons for their
choice and therefore a frivolous and
stupid incentive
might push them in the other direction
the whole thing is demeaning and
infantilizing
with that said we have to admit that
some members of the public are quite
happy to be demeaned and infantilized
that's one of the many
disturbing lessons of the last year it
was in evidence again yesterday when the
cdc
uh around the time that uh bill de
blasio was
making us all vomit made the
announcement that that we've all been
waiting for
um cdc director rochelle wallensky who
just a few days ago was seen testifying
to congress that it's not safe for kids
to go to summer camp she's now decided
that vaccinated americans can take off
their mask
here she is making uh the the
announcement
considering all of these factors the
data on vaccine effectiveness
the science on their ability to protect
against circulating variants
and our growing understanding of the low
risk of transmission to others
combined with universal access to
vaccines for those 12 and older
today cdc is updating our guidance for
fully
vaccinated people anyone who is fully
vaccinated
can participate in indoor and outdoor
activities
large or small without wearing a mask or
physical distancing
if you are fully vaccinated you can
start doing
the things that you had stopped doing
because of the pandemic
we have all longed for this moment
when we can get back to some sense of
normalcy based on the continuing
downward trajectory of cases the
scientific data on the performance of
our vaccines
and our understanding of how the virus
spreads that moment has come
for those who are fully vaccinated
the moment has come i said this is the
announcement we've all been waiting for
i should clarify
some have been waiting for this
announcement i haven't been i've already
been
going maskless everywhere that i can
i've been doing that from the very
beginning
um i didn't need the cdc's permission
and i don't care whether they give it or
not
still this announcement raises some
questions like why now is it safer to go
mask list today than it was yesterday or
last week or a month ago
the the cdc issued guidance in the form
of a handy chart not but
a week or two ago and in that chart they
called for everyone everyone vaccinated
or not
to wear masks everywhere indoors then a
short time later they dramatically
changed course announcing that the
vaccinateds can
take their masks off inside did the
science change in the course of 14 days
does the cdc have scientific data today
that it didn't have two weeks ago these
are all rhetorical questions of course i
can answer them no
there is no new scientific data no the
science did not change
no there's no science-based reason why
the cdc made this announcement today
and not earlier this is part arbitrary
part theater
part politics all manipulation
and it only underscores why you're
better off
reading the science for yourself and
using your common sense
as always here the public health
officials are belatedly confirming what
common sense told us
all along indeed they're confirming the
common sense determinations
that they condemned us for making as
recently as like two days ago
common sense and science all told us
from the from the beginning
that there's no good reason to have
everyone
of all ages wearing masks everywhere all
the time
indoors and outdoors and yet if we
operated according to
that common sense we were castigated
because common sense didn't count unless
the cdc said so
that has been the most disgusting thing
to witness over the last 24 hours since
the cdc's announcement
even more disgusting than bill de blasio
gnawing on his lunch like a damned
warthog
the most disgusting thing has been all
of the people tearfully
thanking the cdc for giving them the
permission to take their masks off
there's been a lot of that kind of thing
on special on cable news especially
here's a cnn host
on the verge of tears so overcome with
gratitude for the liberties she has now
been granted by our
cdc masters i just want to take a moment
to mark this minute because i found
myself
welling up when when dr walensky was
talking and she said it's a we have an
exciting announcement and i still find
myself welling up
even right now because you know you and
i
talked every morning you know during the
past year
about how many more americans were going
to die
you know what was going to happen were
we going to make it to the vaccines were
we all going to survive what was going
to happen
and you know 580 000 americans didn't
make it to this day
you know this day that they say that we
can throw these away that we've all been
clinging to
and here we are i mean we just didn't
know when this day would come but it
feels
a little bit like it's over today
doesn't it you're getting me emotional
too
uh allison i mean gosh i got goosebumps
as you're talking
i mean i it's it's a really important
day
the masks we've all been clinging to i
mean
speak for yourself allison
they really think this is how out of
touch these people are
and they wonder why they have trouble
connecting with
most americans she really thinks that
we've all
been clinging desperately to our masks
no i haven't been you know i would
throw my mask away in celebration or
burn it or something but i don't even
know where it is
um that's how much i've been clinging to
it but if that wasn't quite sickening
enough rachel maddow
over on msnbc says that now with the
cdc's permission
she will have to rewire her brain and
figure out how to be around other
bare-faced people
without having a panic attack let's
listen
everybody had very personal feelings
about it and i realized i did too and
all these questions
part of it is that i feel like i'm gonna
have to rewire myself
so that when i see somebody out in the
world who's not wearing a mask i don't
instantly think
you are a threat or you are selfish or
you are a covid denier and you
definitely haven't been vaccinated
i mean we're going to have to rewire the
way that we look at each other
president biden spoke to that a little
bit today asking for people to president
biden actually and dr fauci both spoke
to that today asking for people to
essentially be patient be compassionate
give people respect for whatever they
decide on this front because
with these with this changing guidance
we're going to now have changing norms
and we got to give each other space
to have feelings about that as we go
through what's going to be a big change
that's going to create a lot of visceral
um a lot of visceral reaction in a lot
of us just in our day to day lives
big day big change so that was all a
really long way of saying
i'm mentally ill you could really
summarize it there
rachel just say i'm mentally ill which
yes we know we know you are but
there's been a lot of this kind of
sentiment expressed people have waited
for the cdc to give them permission to
breathe fresh air they
literally needed permission to breathe
the reason given for this obsequious
submissive
demeanor is that they're you know
following the science
and that's why they're waiting for the
cdc because i'm following the science
well
the cdc is not the science
the national institute of health is not
the science the world health
organization is not
the science these are institutions
comprised of
people and the people are oftentimes
self-interested and highly political
yes they have science-y sounding words
in the names of the organizations
but that doesn't mean that they're
themselves synonymous with
science if you have trouble
understanding this point just think
about this what if i justified
a decision made by a court of law by
saying hey it's the
justice system what do you disagree with
justice
i mean if you disagree with something
the justice system does you must have a
problem with
justice yes it's the justice system
um as in it's a system that's supposed
to enact justice
but the system is made up of people and
those people can be wrong
and often are to act as though the
justice
system is synonymous with justice itself
is as a concept is to engage in the most
debased form of brainless bootlicking
imaginable
it would sound insane for me to make
that argument and it sounds just as
insane
when it comes to science and the cdc
of course all that established the
people who are celebrating today and
popping the champagne because their cdc
or
overlords are allowing them to show
their face in public again are certainly
pitiful and embarrassing and a disgrace
to our country but
they're not nearly as bad as the
countless others who are jealously
clinging to their masks
still refusing to take them off because
they've become psychologically and
emotionally dependent on them
altogether it's clear that the pandemic
and the government's response to it and
the media's fear-mongering over it
have all been simply too much to bear
for many americans who already lacked a
moral and intellectual foundation
who had lived distracted in superficial
lives
and had never even considered the issue
of their own mortality until this past
year
all of these factors together have
ruined many of these people possibly
permanently
they'll never be able to breathe fresh
air again without it causing anxiety
or else they become conditioned like
pavlov's dogs to follow the orders and
edicts of anyone with
health official in their title perhaps
some will return to normal
lives but they'll be ready to abandon
those lives again whenever the next
crisis emerges
whether real or imagined but those of us
who have operated by common sense who
kept living our lives
who used our critical thinking
capacities and made our own decisions
as adults and americans and didn't wait
for anyone's permission to exercise our
basic liberties
we at least come out of this with our
mind sharp
and our dignity intact and maybe we
could take
some solace in that now let's get to our
five headlines
now let's talk about beard supply you
know my my beard it's the one
i think it's my one good trait there's
this i got nothing else going but this
beard but you know if you have a great
beard that's all you need
and people are always asking me how do
you get this great beard well one thing
you got to take care of it and that's
why i use beard supply
and also listen this is your last chance
you can enter to win
the beard supply spring giveaway manly
men they grow beards they grill meat
they drink handcrafted booze i think
that's i think we could all agree on all
three of those statements
and maybe there might be other things
too that men do but certainly those and
thanks to the manliest giveaway ever
some lucky guy will be doing those
things for free enter to win a stash of
goods from beard supply meat church
desert door hallow brothers and more
these are badass brands for the
red-blooded american male one lucky
winner will be chosen this weekend and
this winter will receive a collection of
beard oils
and grooming essentials tools for
grilling and leather care and a 200
gift card for an outdoor menswear
shopping spree you get all of that
you can up your man game with a stash of
goods but this is your last chance so go
to beardsupply.com
giveaway to enter that's beardsupply.com
giveaway and it ends in a matter of
hours so don't delay beardsupply.com
giveaway and good luck
all right so meteorite reports
uh alexandria case of cortez you know
she has it pretty rough um
there's you know she's had many
near-death experiences
where in fact she wasn't near death at
all but um
at least in her mind she's constantly
under attack
and here's another such case uh mediate
reports
representative alexandra casey cortez
has reportedly sought increased security
after representative marjorie
taylor-green
aggressively confronted her in the
capitol building wednesday accusing her
of supporting
terrorists and antifa according to a new
report from the washington post taylor
greene began shouting at aces cortez as
she left the house chamber
um and we have only the report of this i
wish we had a video that'd be great
that'd be fun to watch but there's no
video as far as i know
so this is um the report it says two
washington post reporters witnessed
okay cortez exited the house chamber
late wednesday afternoon ahead of green
who shouted hey alexandria twice in an
effort to get her attention
when occasion cortes did not stop
walking green picked up her pace and
began shouting at her and asking why she
supports antifa
a loosely knit group of far left
activists and black lives matter
falsely labeling them terrorist groups
this this is the washington post framing
by the way with the falsely labeled
because in reality that that is a
correct label but
green also shouted that okay cortez was
failing to defend her radical socialist
beliefs by declining to publicly debate
the freshman from georgia
green shouted you don't care about the
american people why do you support
terrorists and antifa
occasionally cortez did not stop to
answer green only turning around once
and throwing her hands in the air
in an exasperated motion the two
reporters were not close enough to hear
what the new york congresswoman said and
her office declined to discuss
her specific response um and then in a
statement
the okay court has a spokeswoman lauren
hitt
said the following representative greene
tried to begin an argument with
congresswoman akisa cortez
and when representative aka cortez tried
to walk away congresswoman green began
screaming and called
representative casa cortez a terrorist
sympathizer we hope leadership and the
sergeant-at-arms will take real steps to
make congress a safe civil place for all
members and staff
especially as many officers are
discussing reopening
one member has already been forced to
relocate her office
due to congresswoman greene's attacks
yeah her she's just a
what is she drop kicking people in the
hallway
doing cartwheels like some kind of ninja
her attacks but we got to keep everyone
safe
yeah as i said another near-death
experience here for um
for poor alexandria somebody was
raising their voice in her presence oh
oh god no
no she nearly died
first of all everything that marjorie
taylor green reportedly said
is true so let's establish that
and um so they raised she raised her
voice a little bit get over it
sweetheart you'll be fine you gotta call
in security for that
why not it's a good question actually
why
why are you supporting these
organizations why won't you denounce
antifa
pretty good question and achieve cortez
refuses to answer that question so hey
what is it that um
i'm trying to remember what is it that
maxine waters
was urging people to do what was the
word she used oh yeah
confrontational didn't she say that get
more confrontational
she said that multiple times i mean she
told her supporters to get in people's
faces let them know they're not welcome
so at worst representative greene is
merely
taking uh maxine waters advice
and doing as as the democrats and other
democrats do have encouraged
of course i know the difference is that
oh no no no
you're not supposed to do that i was
talking to the so it's only if you have
the correct political views
that's when you're allowed to be
confrontational to the point of even
like burning down a building if you want
to
invade a police station drive everybody
out and burn it to the ground you can do
that
that's confrontation that's okay as long
as you have the correct political views
now it sounds like margery taylor greene
just doesn't accept that
double standard and so she was
responding that way and uh
i don't it's fine deal with it
you know in congress they used to be a
lot more confrontational than that they
used to hit each other
with their with their canes and pokers
from the fireplace
you would have politicians getting into
duels and that kind of thing
so this is really not uh not too
aggressive as compared to that
all right next from yahoo it says
colonial pipeline company
paid nearly five million dollars to
eastern european hackers on friday
contradicting reports earlier this week
that the company had no intention of
paying an extortion fee to help restore
the country's largest fuel pipeline the
company paid the hefty ransom
in difficult to trace cryptocurrency
within hours after the attack
underscoring the immense pressure faced
by the georgia-based operator
um and so they paid they paid the ransom
of 5 million
and now supposedly the pipeline's
getting back online and i think they're
saying
but it'll take a couple weeks before
things maybe get back to normal
um you can't really
yeah you could say that the company here
at least
refused to negotiate with terrorists
because they just give the terrorists
everything they wanted
so that that's one way of not
negotiating not negotiating could go one
way or another and they chose their way
but
uh from a business perspective they're
just looking at this like listen
we can lose 5 million or we could keep
this thing going and lose a lot more
than five million
business decision we're just going to
pay the ransom so for a business
decision from a business standpoint you
can understand it
but i really think we can't it can't be
emphasized enough
just how disturbing it is that we could
have these
foreign hackers 6 000
whatever 5 6 000 miles away other side
of the world
sitting in front of their computers they
press a couple
of buttons and next thing you know we
have a gas
shortage in the united states
that's what happened hackers pressed
some buttons and caused
a gas shortage across the united states
and that makes you wonder what else can
they do
if they can do that pretty easily then
what else what else can they do what
happens when they attack the power grid
where are we then
but you know as we discussed yesterday
the good news is that our intelligence
agencies
um therefore they're not so much focused
on that but they are focused on
promoting diversity and tolerance so
uh if the hackers ever come to come
after the power grid and send us back
into the stone age
that'll be unfortunate but at least
when our civilization is destroyed and
we're in the stone age we will be a
diverse
intolerant stone age civilization
so at least we'll have that
all right speaking of being diverse and
tolerant from the daily wire it says
disney
is revamping the proud family a 20 year
old cartoon sitcom
about an african american family and
will be featuring a cast that includes
two
interracial gay dads whose adopted
daughter is a teenage racial activist
i told you this is the they're going for
gold in the woke olympics with this show
actor zachary quinto and billy porter
both of whom are gay
will be playing barry leibowitz jenkins
and randall leibowitz jenkins
respectively
the two are a couple and mixed-race
adoptive parents to maya
leibowitz-jenkins
a 14-year-old black activist voiced by
kiki palmer
um the show will be titled the proud
family louder and prouder
and apparently this this show aired back
in whatever 2005
or from 2001 to 2005 and
i don't know if it had the gay element
back then but they're injecting that in
now
we are rapidly approaching the point
where there will be more gay parents on
children's tv than exist in reality
we might actually already be there i
don't know
uh and the the difference because
what you hear to justify a lot of this
stuff is that is that um
for so long the all the parents that you
saw on tv and all the couples were all
heterosexual
and that's not representative of of
what's happening in the culture and so
this is just about representing
the reality and and you know making
other
other lifestyles visible and so on and
so forth that's the
that's the justification that's the
argument for it
but there's one there are there are a
number of significant differences
i'll just point to one that
for so long when you had say you know
just a cartoon and you had a mom and a
dad and a kid in a cartoon or a sitcom
or whatever
nobody was trying to make a point there
wasn't any political
point being made by the fact that you
had a mom and a dad and a kid this is
just a family
um the the heterosexual the the sexual
nature of the parents relationship
didn't it wasn't a subject it didn't
come up
it wasn't the point
but now with all of these shows it is it
is all about
making the point the storyline is
secondary
whatever humor they try to inject into
it is secondary every plot is secondary
because all of that is just providing a
forum to make the ideological point
that they want to make with this
and that is a pretty big difference and
that's also why all of these shows are
terrible
because it's not about the story
once they they as far as as far as
they're concerned there is no story to
tell
they've made a show with an interracial
gay parents
and that's it that's all that's all they
wanted to do
every story that they tell within that
context is secondary
all right next people.com
has this says jeff bezos is eyeing a new
ride
a massive one-of-a-kind super yacht the
amazon ceo
57 reportedly plans to purchase a 417
foot long yacht
that spans several decks and boasts
three enormous mass
it also has a support yacht with a
helipad
the vessel known only as project 271
reportedly costs roughly 500 million
dollars so
jeff bezos is getting a half a billion
dollar
yacht and it has its own support yacht
that comes with it that's when you
really crossed
the threshold into uh obscene
wealth which which really he crossed
that threshold a long time ago
now of course this this story came out a
few days ago
and a lot of people especially people on
the left were upset about this and were
talking about how disgusting it is that
you know jeff bezos has a he's getting a
500 million dollar yacht with a support
yacht and how dare he and
you know that couldn't that money go to
the poor couldn't that money go to
better causes and so on
um i think what often happens in these
arguments
that the left says that says oh this is
immoral it's gratuitous
it's obscene it's it's greedy it's all
these things
and then you have the right people on
the right defending it
by saying yeah but it's it's creating
jobs and think about all the people now
who are hired
to build the yacht and to maintain it
and those are you know those are this
it's a job creating thing and that's
good now the thing is
i i look at this argument and to me
both sides are actually correct and it
doesn't happen very often
but i think both sides are right here um
on one hand yeah it does create jobs
so it is good in in that sense there's a
lot hundreds of people
if you're getting a 500 million dollar
yacht there are hundreds and hundreds of
people involved in making it maintaining
it all that kind of stuff
um and so i'm sure all of them and their
families are are quite grateful for
for jeff bezos's greed um
and his his obscene wealth but it is
also true
that it is obscene
and um it is greedy
and there really is no moral
justification for that
if you've got that kind of money to
spend
you're spending it on a temple to
yourself and to your own vanity
and who could deny that of course that
money would be better
not because the government takes it but
of his own free will and volition
he should choose to take that money and
use it give it yes give it to those who
are in need
as christians right we cannot deny that
claim at all we just have to what would
jesus do what what what
is what is jesus christ's opinion about
about this
does he think that when you got all that
money you should spend it on a yacht for
yourself
um or should you give it to the poor
what do we think jesus says about that i
think we know
there's no doubt about it um
it is
and we have to be able to draw this
distinction that's another thing a lot
of people on the right i think struggle
to draw this distinction
where any time you criticize what rich
people spend their money on
people on the right get their antennas
up and they
because they think you're making a pitch
for socialism and they say oh but they
have the right to spend it
they might have the right to but that
doesn't make it right too
okay there's a difference sometimes
between what you have a right to do and
what is right
to do and you have the right to do a lot
of things
that aren't actually right to do
and that's the distinction with all that
said
um it must also be pointed out
that the leftists who are criticizing
someone like jeff bezos
for a 500 million yacht even though
their moral point is correct
um that it is vanity and it is greed
and uh it it and of course he should be
using that in in
you know in in more productive ways for
those who are in need
uh it it it's hard to deny right like
you've got
jeff bezos in his 500 million yacht
meanwhile you've got
some people living on twelve thousand
dollars a year and can barely feed their
their kids um
but the problem is that on the left
you actually don't have the moral
standing to make that argument
you don't have the moral framework for
it
because by by your philosophy by your
worldview
jeff bezos is living his truth as a
billionaire
you know just he's living his truth
he's enjoying his life he's enjoying the
luxuries of life he's living each moment
um trying to maximize his pleasure
and his own personal enjoyment in each
moment and for
most people on the left that for them
that's the whole point of life there is
no other point of life beyond that
there also is no objective morality
morality is subjective
they're moral relativists and so
this is right for him it's what he wants
to do you you have no basis
to criticize it
there's no there's not a much of a moral
difference between a rich guy
spending his money to make himself feel
good and you know
building temples to his own vanity not a
lot of difference between that
and um you know a glutton who just
gorges on food and gets really fat we're
supposed to celebrate someone like that
or a woman who goes and sleeps around
and you know gets abortions and kills
her kids
to escape the consequence we're supposed
to celebrate that woman
because she's living her truth living
her life as she sees fit
enjoying her life who are we to judge
jeff bezos belongs
in that category
with the gluttons and um
you know and all of that it's it's it's
all in the same category
so in order to criticize him
you have to adopt some kind of objective
moral framework
where you recognize that people have
moral responsibilities and moral duties
that go beyond their own whims
and that sometimes a person may really
want to do something and it may make
them feel good to do it
but they shouldn't do it because there's
some moral truth that is above and
beyond
themselves there is no way to criticize
rich people for buying yachts unless you
have unless that is your world view
unless that unless you accept that truth
which the left doesn't so
they have no room to criticize
unfortunately
all right let's move to um
reading the uh youtube comments in fact
actually one more story here
although this is kind of interesting
this is from d-d-n-y-uz.com whatever
that is
it says just how many friends can one
person have in a 1993 study
robin dunbar a british anthropologist
theorized that humans can have no more
than about 150 meaningful relationships
a measure that became known as dunbar's
number
but researchers at stockholm university
published a paper last week
calling that number into question
finding that people could have far more
friends if they put in the effort
jonah lind and author of the study said
we can learn thousands of digits of pie
and we can engage with lots of people
um then we will become better at having
relationships with lots of people
in his original research dr dunbar
studied monkeys and apes and determined
that the size of the neocortex
the part of the brain responsible for
conscious thought correlated with the
size of groups they lived among the
neocortex in humans is even larger so he
extrapolated that the ideal group size
was on average 150. in the new study dr
lin said
he and his team used updated data sets
and statistical methods and found that
the size of the neocortex does not limit
the number of connections
people can maintain dunbar's number he
said has been criticized for quite a
time
uh dr lin's team found that no maximum
number of friendships could be
established with any precision
so the original thought was that you can
have no more than 150 friends
and now we're being told that oh you
could have a lot more than that
i would think that the real number is
quite a bit smaller than that
there is no way a human being can
maintain 150
meaningful friendships i can't even
remember and i guess
i can only speak from my own experience
but i can't even remember the names of
150 people
i i could say right now i don't think i
personally know the name
of up to 150 people if we're not
counting like famous people people in
the public eye
but in my own personal life are there
150 people that i personally know who i
who i could name them all
i'm not even sure that i could and now
you could have meaningful
relationships and friendships with 150
no it's i
what's what's the real how many
meaningful
lasting because i think in order to be a
friendship it has to be that meaningful
and lasting
um relationships can you have outside of
your own family
i'm gonna put the number at
i don't know two three maybe
maybe a little bit more than that this
is another thing we've seen in our
culture is this cheapening of the idea
of
friends and i think um i think even
though this original idea of 150 friends
came before the advent of social media
still
the advent of social media has pushed
this along
because we talk about you know your
friends on facebook and the people that
you
follow on twitter or instagram or
whatever and yeah you could have
thousands of thousands of people but
none of them are actually your friends
you don't have any actual connection no
intimate relationship with any of them
um and so if you take a very
shallow idea of friendship then sure the
sky's the limit
but a friendship means something i'm
gonna say
i'll put it at two you can have two
friends pick your two and that's it
all right let's move now to read the
youtube comments this is from username
ethanol uh says imagine the scene it's
the middle of a war it's raining bullets
the entire us army is crawled up in a
corner crying
but how the enemy is misgendering them
it's safe to say that we are completely
doomed
um yeah well that that assumes
that when whatever superpower comes to
invade us in conquerors that we would
actually fight back at all which i'm not
sure that uh
that that would happen at this point
ojh says i'm in the break room at work
listening to co-workers talk about how
they disagree with the new order that
vaccinated people shouldn't wear
masks they're saying what about flu
season and i'm afraid to not wear one
no joke we knew this would happen though
yeah we did
this a lot of people there you heard
rachel maddow saying she's actually
right about that
that uh that people's brains have been
rewired in this way
that for a lot of people
it gives them anxiety now
think about how deeply someone has to
have been
affected that now to simply see
another person's face cause that causes
them real anxiety
and anger so rachel maddow was saying
she is anxious
and afraid and and angry
when she sees another person's bare face
and she starts to make all these
assumptions about them
she's admitting that but she doesn't
really see a problem with it
it's a huge problem um christian says
matt sounded so white reading tori's
tweets the way he said
effed around and found out was hilarious
well i don't consider sounding white to
be an insult i mean i am white so
whatever uh i'm not sure exactly what
you mean i think i did sound
intimidating
gosh dang it you big goofball you're
gonna f around and find out mister
you're telling me that's not
intimidating come on
uh j.a says i hit the like button
because i appreciate a man who takes
charge and tells me what to do
tomato joe says i wasn't gonna like but
then matt started yelling and i panicked
i may not like it but it's effective
yeah you know what i started doing this
new strategy instead of begging people
to hit like
demanding it and i gotta say over the
last two shows you can go and check
yourself on youtube if you want
the like ratio is way up it's like
doubled
i think i've cracked the code you don't
ask people to hit like
you you you demand
hit like like now
do it we'll see
we'll see if we can keep this going
imagine someone coming in just at that
moment with no context
and how insane i would sound and look
but then again even with the context i
sound and look insane
just in general i suppose and uh
finally chris schwartz says hey matt i'm
a i'm a youth football coach i've
honestly never seen a kid get
get a concussion you would be surprised
what kind of hits they can take
but in saying that i would also take
that as an extremely good coaching
opportunity i've always coached my kids
head has got to stay up in fact a kid
lowers his head on my team he's running
laps i preach that
head up all times proper tackling if i
was coaching
them kids that smaller kid would
definitely have been able to tackle him
and he would have
have the right form both of them had
their heads up if not they both would
have been running laps
the problem with youth football is the
coaching yeah we played the clip of the
from some sort of youth football league
i think here
locally in in tennessee at least of um
a tackling drill drill among really
young kids and
uh the coach is filming it and laughing
while the one kid is way outmatched and
doesn't have proper form
gets blown up head helmet to helmet
contact
smacks his head on the ground uh you
know brain injury written all over
a hit like that i looked it up after the
show and apparently
um apparently this is from a year ago
and i don't know why the clip is making
the rounds now but it's from a year ago
and uh i and and the coach did get fired
after that
so i i
am always hesitant to to say that people
should lose their jobs but something
like that
yeah you you are amused
by possible head trauma to very young
children uh yeah i would say you don't
belong you don't belong in
coaching football you really don't
belong around kids at all i would say
you know if there's one thing that
authoritarians don't know
it's that they're being authoritarian
perhaps they see virtue while we see it
for what it really is a bunch of
delusional elites determined to strip us
of our freedoms
unless we want to live under their
identity obsessed mob rule it's
important
that we know how to stop them that's why
ben shapiro wrote his new book the
authoritarian moment in it
he gives some background on how we got
here and tips on how to fight back
so if you want to preserve your
individual rights and protect the ones
you love from mob rule the authoritarian
moment
is now available for pre-order at amazon
barnes noble or any other
major bookseller also if you're a fan of
watching candace drop some truth bombs
now is your chance to see her in action
tickets to join candace's live show
live studio audience i've actually been
asked about this many times how do you
get
in to watch the show well here it is uh
so you can stop bugging me damn it
you can go uh they're available only to
all access members and limited to her
monday tapings throughout the month of
june plus you'll get 20
off an all-access membership right now
by using code all access at checkout
just head to dailywire.com tickets to
secure your spot hurry though
seating is limited and candace's show is
in high demand so spots will go fast
again just head to
dailywire.com tickets to be a part of an
experience so beautiful
it'll be bring a tear to a leftist eye
all right let's get now to our daily
cancellation
so today we consider another case of
somebody getting cancelled
after things they posted on the internet
a long time ago resurface
as always the term resurface is an
intentionally but dishonestly passive
way of phrasing and it makes it sound
like the thing was locked in a chest
under the sea and happened to lodge
itself loose
and you know bubble to the surface sort
of like in the movie the mask
for any aficionados of 90s jim carrey
films in any case the point is that this
is not a passive or accidental process
actual humans have to go looking for
this stuff and then they have to find it
they have to spread it around offer the
express purpose of destroying the life
of another human and this time the
target was
american idol contestant caleb kennedy i
must admit that i
never heard of caleb kennedy before and
honestly i didn't know that american
idol was still on the air i really
i thought it went off the air years ago
but apparently it is on the air
and caleb kennedy was on the air until
now the new york post has a story quote
american idol top five finalist caleb
kennedy has left the show after a video
surface showing him next to someone
wearing what appears to be a ku klux
klan hood
a representative for the show confirmed
to the post that kennedy will no longer
be moving forward in the competition
the singer 16 posted a statement about
his departure on instagram on wednesday
he said quote
hey y'all this is going to be a bit of a
surprise but i'm no longer going to be
on american idol
there was a video that surfaced on the
internet and it displays actions that
were not meant to be taken in that way
i was younger and did not think about
the actions but that's not an excuse i
want to say sorry to all my fans and
everyone who i've let down
i'll be taking a little time off social
media to better myself but saying that
i know this has hurt and disappointed a
lot of people and made less people lose
respect for me i'm so sorry i pray that
i can one day regain your trust in who i
am
and have your respect thank you for
supporting me now um
kenny kennedy's mother has come out and
clarified that the video
doesn't depict a clan hood kennedy is
with a friend who's wearing a costume
inspired by a movie they've both seen
there was a movie called the stranger's
prey at night
and sure enough you can go look it up
you'll find if you do
that the main bad guy wears a white hood
and uh not a clan hood just a white
scary hood
and it also came out at around the time
that the video was taken
so the story seems to line up speaking
of which
caleb kennedy is currently 16 years old
that movie came out four years ago
the video was taken when he was 12 12
years old
he had to leave the show because of a
video from when he was 12.
think about that for a moment if there's
going to be any controversy stemming
from that video it should really be that
his mom
shouldn't have let him watch a rated r
slasher film at the age of 12. but aside
from that
there's nothing here in fact let's
pretend for a moment that caleb really
was sitting next to a friend
who really was joking around and
pretending to wear a clan hood
he wasn't but what if he was so they
were 12. i repeat again 12 years old
it is the height of both absurdity and
cruelty to hold someone responsible
for a joke they made at the age of 12.
insult to injury in this case is that
very clearly the joke had nothing to do
with the kkk
caleb kennedy had not a thing to
apologize for he hasn't disappointed
anyone let anyone down
he hasn't hurt anyone's feelings and if
he hasn't anyone's feelings screw them
who cares
their feelings are irrelevant
i'm glad their feelings are i hope their
feelings are get are more hurt
it is it is everyone else who owes
him an apology you know for doing this
to a kid for putting him in this
position
and normally my policy as you know is to
not defend
any canceled person who apologizes but i
make an exception here because even now
the kid is only 16.
i can no more hold him responsible for
mishandling a pr crisis at 16
that i can for a supposedly but not
really offensive joke he made it 12.
there there are things that that we
should hold kids accountable for things
like for example
carjacking and murdering someone as
those two teen girls in dc did
though the court system in that case is
just giving them a slap on the wrist
yet a sane society would not hold kids
accountable at all
in any serious or public way at least
for jokes they make or opinions they
express
we however are not a sane society or
maybe that's letting us off the hook
because i often times as a kind of
verbal shorthand we'll call things crazy
or insane i feel like that's this is the
most common words you hear on this show
um but but really oftentimes the things
that i'm calling crazy or insane
are neither of those things in reality
much of this is considered an
intentional
cruelty for many in the cancel mob
they get a thrill out of tearing
somebody down and watching them crash
and burn
even a kid there are many in this
country who are failures
in their own lives and they're lonely
and they're miserable
and they've achieved nothing of note
they have no talents they have no skills
they have no ambitions
they have no plans for the future they
do nothing with their life they sit
around watching tv and on the internet
that's all they do staring at screens
they live pointless empty despairing
awful lives of their own making they
feel powerless and forgotten and nearly
non-existent
because they because they're losers and
the world doesn't pay attention to them
and shouldn't pay attention
to them because they have nothing
interesting to say or anything valuable
to offer
and so for these miserable wretched
nothings
the only way that they can feel an
approximation of
joy is to destroy someone else's joy
the only way they can feel power is to
cut someone else down
a kid on american idol top five
living his dream achieving remarkable
things at the age of 16
hasn't hurt anybody and these people
hate him for it
and we're eager for any chance to cut
him down to size
nothing personal really when the
canceled mob comes for you it's not
because of you
it's because of them you're a blade of
grass that poked its head a little too
far above the rest and these
these other withered little blades down
in the dirt
want to make themselves feel taller by
bringing you down closer to them
that's what drives much of the canceled
culture envy misery resentment
a tale as old as time there's also
plenty of cowardice driving it too
institutions have to bend to the whims
of these
losers american idol could have easily
stuck by their guy told the mob to get
lost and say hey listen shut up he was a
kid
just stop but that would require that
would require
some tiny semblance of moral courage
and that's too much to ask for and
completing the picture there's also
ideology and politics feeding into it
caleb kennedy is a white male anytime a
white male can be painted as a racist
it's considered a win by the left
whether the white male actually is
racist is of course irrelevant
so all of these factors converge and
together they create the unholy
concoction
that we know as cancel culture and for
that reason
perhaps somewhat ironically all of those
involved
in this are certainly cancelled
and we will leave it there for the day
and the week i hope you have a great
weekend i'll talk to you on monday
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky
the show is edited by sasha thomachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nikka geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me
andrew clavin